but this is a walk that probably took
about 45 minutes something like that
yeah roughly started around 8 40 then
the last kind of known whereabouts of
Nicola was that phone the dog Willow and
the lead all by the bench where we were
earlier on today and that was found at
around 9 30 by a lady who actually lives
nearby so um yeah you know a usual walk
though for Nicola nothing out of the
ordinary that was happening on that walk
of course into that 10 minute window
which police say that she's been
completely unaccounted for yeah okay and
as far as the police are concerned
they're no clearer now really as to what
happened to her no evidence no clues a
family still questioning what on Earth
has happened yes a main working
hypothesis but police also stressing
they're keeping an open mind the big
question is is three weeks ago when
Nicola bully went missing one what
happened in that 10 minute window yeah
so what we're going to do is we're going
to start from the car park which is
where she came with the dog and the kids
dropped them off at school and then
we're going to walk along the road and
just give you an overview walk along the
road walk down by the river and then
from there we are going to walk around
the fields and try to get an idea of
what might have happened so that
happened at exactly 8 40. yep from here
what then what happened so Nicola came
parked up her car here she dropped off
her kids at school she would have taken
her Bungalow out of the car park
as she normally did and walked her along
this path next to the car park of the
tennis club and the school
and along the school it's been around as
you want to have a look rather than yeah
there we go and this is a very normal
route for Nicola almost every single
morning this is exactly what she would
have done her kids
coming to the school to our left as well
and this is a busy road Inskip down
there is where the family home is so she
would have come down this road and then
onto the road up there a very busy main
road yeah Blackpool Lane it is yeah and
the police have stressed about Blackpool
Lane because there are hundreds of cars
700 Vehicles yeah that would have passed
through that morning and so they are
clear they want to try and speak to
every single one of those drivers to get
as much dash cam footage as they
possibly can to try and piece together
what exactly has gone on so you want to
cross this road
and would have walked down this path
which heads up to not only the bridge
which she crossed but in fact the church
which she would have passed a church
which has been a real focal point over
the last three weeks for a lot of the
the community for Nicholas family
when she's
when when they've come here to to kind
of you know just shine a bit of Hope
over what's happened over the last three
weeks okay so 16th century Church very
beautiful building just uh walking past
some of our our colleagues also
broadcasting
um from here the reason it's so poignant
today is that it's three weeks today
since
um she disappeared
yep three weeks today is what she was
yeah it's a really lovely church I've
been inside as well it's really lovely
the vicar has spoken to us
a couple of weeks ago spoke of how this
community is really in shock after what
happened three weeks ago and I actually
met Nicholas sister inside this church
just a couple of days ago she was
leaving a message on a tree that's
inside there with the yellow love hearts
messages of Hope for Nicola and she
would have come up here
to this Iron Bridge which again has been
another real focal point of the last
three weeks look at all these beautiful
ribbons daffodils that have been tied up
with messages Nicholas partner came down
here leaving a message on one of them as
well and as we just go a bit forward we
get to the other side of the bridge and
essentially the start of the path which
is next to the river this is the path
that runs along the river wire and it
was 8 43 yeah this time
quite a pace she was walking out isn't
it yeah it was yeah it was we've you
know walked down she's got a dog with
her probably the dog you know running a
bit ahead of you you're a dog walking
yourself a river wire there
yeah that's the river you can see
actually you know there is a bit of a
flow to the river this morning
um but you know this was all normal for
Nicola yeah you know walking along this
path you know the river to a right the
dog was screwing off ahead of her
dog off the lead by now
yeah that's I mean I'm not entirely sure
whether the dog is still on the lead or
off the lead but certainly when she got
to the fields a bit further up the dog
was definitely uh off the lead
but this is this is her normal walk and
this is of course this this river bank
which has been scoured by police not
only in the Water by divers by
specialist teams but on the banks as
well by forensic police officers they've
really investigated and thoroughly
checked the banks and the water bed gone
down to the city and and back again on
several occasions yeah with the scuba
team yeah there has been look you know
there's no denying care there's been a
lot of resource pumped into this
investigation over the last few weeks
yeah there has been you know a really
high-tech equipment used as well to try
and see if they can locate Nicola of
course their working hypothesis is that
she did end up in this River you can
just see as we go around here as well
actually yeah yeah this is the way yeah
now what the police say is that it is
very likely that if Nicola was in the
water the force of the river could have
that the flow of the river could have
Center over that Weir and that's where
you see the water picks up the pace
picks up
and she could have gone further
Downstream okay but you know this has
also been a point where police have been
launching their boats off here to try
and get
into some parts of the water to get near
yeah to some of the deep Parts where
they can do some of their diving and see
if they can get anything so just to
clarify what's going on here we are
trying to walk at a pace that she would
have been walking out this is exactly
what would have happened three weeks um
ago she's walked she's dropped the kids
off at school she's walked along the
Blackpool Lane there and she's moved on
to this path that will take her to her
normal route where she walks the dog
Willow yeah and look at this you know
posters everywhere now yeah Nicholas
face is plastered over this Village yeah
we saw this morning driving in you know
even miles out
missing posters someone with some
evidence who may have been driving that
Friday morning
do you know where Nicola is did you see
anything did you see her entering the
path did you see her leaving the path
was that a possibility yeah but now
we're just walking into a path which
basically takes us to where we've been
broadcasting from this morning yeah and
the next juncture of where people last
saw her yes exactly you know we've seen
already a number of dog walkers this
morning it is a busy dog walking area
plenty of dog walkers
um almost every morning I've been told
okay that Friday morning the 27th of
January very cool it was very cold yeah
it was really cold and slippy slippy
because of the mud and the ice yeah and
the ice and there weren't as many dog
walkers as they usually would have been
right that morning I mean if there were
more maybe we'd have more answers by now
you know it's a it's a my new thing that
the weather wasn't the greatest it could
have seen more people out on the
footpaths
walking their dogs but you know we're
heading to the fields now where Nicola
was and there's a lower field and an
upper field yeah yeah so there's a
there's a lower field to our left as we
get through this kissing gate and this
gate actually I think we have to mention
because
it will play an important role in when
we talk a bit about
what happened later on
you just get through it yeah so this is
what I mean this is uh basically what we
call a kissing gate isn't it so this
could have been the dog was stuck this
side so she it couldn't come if she went
back this way and that the X that's come
the area that we just walked along that
is where there's no CCTV we go down this
way yes so Nicola would have come
through the gate
and she would have walked onto what is
now the lower field
just a big open space I can imagine
it's not been confirmed but I can
imagine police uh are suggesting that
Nicola would have taken Willow off the
lead here yeah of course and let her
roam about yeah you're a dog walker you
know that's what wood
saying here
um
and we're going to get to the spot now
where she was spotted by another dog
walker yeah that happened in a couple of
minutes time so that was around 8 50. so
we'll get to that shortly so because
what she would have done is and I've
speaking spoken to dog walkers over the
last three weeks I've been here this is
a normal route for all the locals people
who knew Nicola Nicola herself you can
see actually see the pattern yeah you
know it's It's A Worn Path people do
this on the regular
and this is where she would have
brought Willow as normal that morning so
what's striking me at the moment is that
she had quite a lick on so you know she
she wasn't sauntering no she wasn't like
um alone with her thoughts she was
properly moving
yeah but I think there is also given
everything that's come out over the last
few days okay
her family and her friends and I think
people in general who are watching this
will be thinking what were Nicholas
thoughts that Friday morning how was she
feeling what was going through her mind
we know she was on her meeting call we
know she texted a friend all that kind
of stuff but what was going through that
Mum of two's mind particularly when just
over two weeks before that morning she
had a visit from police because of
concerns for welfare yeah a medical team
went to the home on the 17th of January
and they haven't told us anything more
than that but we do know that the police
have referred themselves to the
complaints committee
um as a direct result of that um moment
but if we just pause here because before
we get
to the upper field it was around this
time roughly about 850 that Nicola was
then spotted by another dog walker yeah
someone who knew her walking around the
lower field with their dog as well the
two dogs actually interacted before the
other dog walker went off and took the
river path which we've just come down
and Nicola then carried on with her dog
Willow and we wanted we wanted to do
this um retracing of her steps today to
illustrate to people at home
what had happened this you know there's
so much intense interest on what has
happened she's the front page picture on
all the papers seemingly every day and
yeah it's difficult to paste place
things together and sort of do this sort
of walk I suppose especially when you're
in such a rural area look this is such a
quaint Village it's a rural quaint
Village in a rural part of Lancashire
you know it's hard to picture exactly
what went on we've seen Nicholas face
you know but what is the story behind
Nicola bully what happened to her in
that 10 minute window and that's what
hopefully we can paint an image of what
led up
to that's in the upper field yes so now
we're heading into the upper field this
is
so she obviously had an interaction with
the dog walker in the in the lower field
and then she moved uh here to the upper
field it actually just goes up this this
bank here and then we get into the upper
field and that's where and she had her
mind she usually walked yeah she had her
mind on work because we know that in a
minute or two she would have messaged
her boss yeah and I think that's a
really important uh he's a bit muddy
here yeah it's a really important thing
to notice actually that you know
um Nicola that was interesting Nicola
was um you know thinking about work you
know she was thinking about work and the
police have gathered that from the
evidence of her phone her phone which
was left on the bench still unlocked
yeah you know they will have
forensically examined that
um and they will have seen that okay she
sent emails she sent texts it was in a
couple of minutes time actually that she
would have
been texting and or emailing and walking
and on the left
you can see the river wire
so the place has slowed a bit because
she's texting and emailing well you
think you know you think keeping an eye
on Willow you know just having chatted
to a friend thinking about what she's
emailing to her boss yeah is this the
rock wire as well this is yeah this is
all the river wires yeah yeah okay so
that's the where it kind of meanders
round yeah and then heads uh Downstream
but look a vast open field yeah again a
trodden path yeah obviously worn as dog
uses usually would use we've seen some
this morning taking this route yeah as
well and very shortly she would have
just been finishing her email off which
goes to her boss
yeah and um and so she's looking at the
dog she's making sure the dog's all
right you know from my own experience
you keep an eye on them but you're doing
other things as well the Sheep across
the way they're just obviously keeping
an eye on what's going on and then she
sends the email yep at 8 53 police say
right now three weeks ago Nicola hit
send yep and an email was sent to her
boss yeah
and police basically say that you know
that's an important juncture because we
can get a sense that yes she was active
she was on her phone and she was
essentially you know if you're emailing
your boss you're in a fairly decent
frame of mind you know that email didn't
suggest anything otherwise it was a
standard work email yeah and so that's
an important piece
in this route so she would have carried
on here you know with Willow email sent
maybe phone back in the pocket maybe
actually one thing we have noticed K is
Nicola and friends have told us this
Nicola used to take so many photos when
she was out walking right you know her
family shared photos with her with
Willow of of her uh to us you know so
many photos when she'd be out walking
she'd have a Fitbit on
Snapchat was it no that wasn't so yeah
that would have been very useful for the
police but it hadn't been synced up for
a few days yeah and now she's thinking
about doing a teams call well yeah A
team's call would have started at around
nine o'clock so in about six minutes
time so so she's thinking about it it's
a work team's call and she's thinking
okay I need to go on that call for nine
o'clock yeah meantime walking by the
river with the dog potentially taking
photographs I don't think she took any
that day did she I'm bitterly cold as
well remember you know Nicola was well
kind of padded up with her clothes
shutter a full-length black kind of
padded jacket on she had Wellies on she
had socks her hat a scarf and you know
she was well wrapped up because it was
bitterly cold that morning and muddy
yeah like it is right now and you know
we can see kind of holes and big kind of
divots in the ground but again she was
used to all this she did it almost every
morning she was used to it there was
nothing out of the ordinary for her
whatsoever the last images we've seen of
her are getting in the car aren't they
it's a bit windy forgive me hopefully
you can still hear us
um getting in the car with the kids yeah
and the dog and that was from the
the security at home yes from the front
camera at home and actually you know it
was released it was handed To Us by some
of Nicola's friends you know they were
like look this is what she looked like
on that morning grainy images but we you
know we want to share these so people
can jog their memories and get an
understanding of where she was
what she was doing what she looked like
and you know those were the last images
we've seen of nickler on that Friday
morning
loading the car as she normally would
and and starting her journey to head to
the school yeah we know that the family
are watching us this morning yeah it's
so difficult for them look I mean I've
been in touch with this family for the
last three weeks
I interviewed them
the the you know her sister Louise her
father Ernie
her mom Dot
it was it was really really tough
because they were just clueless with you
know no answers no evidence
no idea where their sister daughter a
mum a partner has gone to you know I
think the words that they used with me
Kay was that feels like she's vanished
Into Thin Air
that's what they've said and you know
because there's that 10 minute window
which
no one's got any clue what happened to
her and the family you know have had to
be incredibly strong over the last three
weeks because this is a case that we've
seen has taken so many twists and turns
it's had involvement from you know every
Tom Dick and Harry you know on social
media people trying to be involved in
being armchair detectives such a shame
that the family is so impacted by that
you know
um social media it can it can be such a
a poisonous place to be I'm so sorry
that they are impacted so badly yeah I
mean it's you know and they have been
they have been wonderful with us as well
you know giving us information about
Nicola and telling us exactly you know
what kind of a woman she really was but
look here we're heading now
on the path which essentially leads
towards the bench so if we
maybe slow down here a bit maybe we've
been walking slightly so she would she
would have been looking at you know what
was the team's call about it that starts
in a couple of minutes what was it about
so this was a team's call that she would
have then logged on to a work team's
call
the police have actually said that she
wasn't speaking she was just listening
and actually what they said is that
while she was walking she had her phone
out in front of her listening that was
apparently quite normal for Nicola to do
the call would have been on speaker
there would have been other people
talking my camera was off her camera was
off okay and it was just it was just
logged on for her to listen essentially
to what was going on in the call and
that's a really important yeah she was a
mortgage advisor
and her dad had actually told us just a
few days before she went missing you
know he was so chuffed because she just
you know signed off a deal she was
incredibly happy you know she was in
good spirits and I had many anybody seen
her here or there were the two sightings
just the other so just to show you the
other side of the field just there that
she'd walked up and then walked around
in a big loop if you will yep so just
just up on this side yeah
um someone actually did spot Nicola a
witness spotted uh Nicola with her dog
Willow uh they actually then police
spoke to that witness to get more
information they they put out a picture
of the witness that got in touch with
the witness they spoke to them and they
got some information from the witness
just to piece together the timeline of
what we're doing this morning but you
know this is this is a a vast area as we
can see the lower field the upper field
it's a normal move she takes Willow all
the way around and her walk would have
carried on you know I think is always
one side or the other yeah exactly and I
think look you know you walk with your
dogs she would have taken it nice and
easy
I mean the bags are steep here
um it has to be it has to be said and
they would have been slippy but it you
know you would have thought
um most people would be able to get out
of that unless there was some way where
they were injured and couldn't yeah I
mean look there are a whole different
number of questions if the police's main
hypothesis is true K that nickel ended
up in the water the big question is is
why and and how did she essentially end
up in the water they're the two things
that police will really be trying to
answer and that's why they've scoured
this River endlessly to see if there's
any evidence yeah so if you're just
tuning our way we are retracing the
steps of Nicola bully
um three weeks ago today it's nine
o'clock and she would have been on a
teams call about now yeah it was about
it's a minute about a minute's time or
so she logged into that team school I
imagine the meeting started at nine
o'clock Nicola logged in about one
minute past nine yeah she would have
held the phone out yeah yep she was
actually she was just walking along this
upper field here yeah she
would have held the phone out in front
of her sorry police said and that's
where that's what you do isn't it yeah
you've got it on speaker yeah you hold
it out in front of you yeah
um and she wasn't talking she wasn't on
video it was just it would have been
slower here because she was listening to
what was being said yeah and again you
know as I mentioned her dad said in
relation to work she was in good spirits
she just as a mortgage advisor had just
got a deal through so she was happy
about that and you know she sent a an
email to her boss that morning around
eight minutes prior to that and you know
she was she was in good spirits it would
see him at the time but the big question
is is that what was going through her
mind you know what was Nicola feeling
that morning we know
she had struggles with alcohol as police
have have revealed we know you know she
was struggling with the menopause
and we know that 17 days prior to her
going missing police had gone to her
home
after reports for concern for welfare
how much of a role everything is focused
on this River though isn't it everything
that the kids are kids are at school
they're safe they're happy they're well
the dogs with her we've seen them all
put in the car but the police continue
to focus on this River yeah and it
really has been the focal point of all
of this K you know from day one you know
police had teams here searching around
the Riverbanks searching the area where
she was last seen and then every single
day since there's been so much focus it
will actually turn probably around
towards the end of week two we notice
that police had actually told us they
were focusing their search Downstream so
we're talking you know a good few miles
Downstream comes out near Morecambe yeah
exactly and and actually they were
searching in the scene at one point you
know there were boats out in the sea
searching there and making their way
Upstream to just catch any evidence you
know what would have been what would
have been quite interesting is that they
were actually searching a lot of the
police were actually searching lot of
the banks because if Nicola had been in
the water it could have been likely she
could have been caught somewhere you
know there could have been a piece of
clothing that could have been caught
onto a branch perhaps on the bank and so
that's been also a very big focal point
for police as they continue their search
so let's recap what we know so far then
she dropped the kids off she walks
across the road there and then onto
Blackpool Lane Blackpool Lane
and it's a busy road I mean the pace
that we were walking out we're working
on timings that we've been given and
people so she was walking really quickly
until she got into the lower field yes
then she starts to slow down and then
she gets here yeah and she must have
stopped because you know I think the
place where she potentially stopped was
actually on the lower field yeah over
here where she met another dog walker
yeah and they they actually had a chat
the dogs had a bit of a play together
you know someone that she knew as well
and so you know I think probably there
was a bit of a break there for a few
minutes yeah as she as she chatted with
that person and police look police will
have spoken to that witness got details
of what the conversation was like got
details of what Nicola was like that
morning as well because that would be so
crucial to their investigation for all
different avenues that police are
investigating but she would have spent a
good few minutes chatting with uh that
witness that police say has come forward
and spoken to them who had a dog a dog
walker who was you know a new Willow and
knew who Nicola was and then she carried
her walk along to the upper field where
we've just actually come round slightly
from she sent the email to her boss
there
then she would have come further and
still on the upper field she would have
dialed into her team's call so that was
one past nine dialing into her meeting
with work and then in a few minutes time
actually approximately police say
because I can't pin exact timing
locations she was then seen by another
witness and that happened roughly police
suggest at around 10 past nine so we're
still a few minutes away from that so it
would suggest that actually slow down
here yeah yeah and actually probably
okay you know you've got a dog as dog
walkers do
just let her dog roam around a bit you
know off the lead run around a bit she's
let the kids drop the kids off at school
she's got a bit of time on her hands it
would suggest and that's why it's taken
you know a bit of time for her to make
her way round lower Field Upper field
and by the river wire here yeah and then
that she is seen again in about three or
four minutes yeah roughly about four
minutes time yeah a witness and again
someone who who knows Nicola actually
then uh saw her again and it will have
been on it will have been on this
stretch yeah of a path so adjacent to
the the upper field is what police are
suggesting this route all the way around
that we've taken it's not a big route as
a dog walker it's not a big route you
know this this Loop is going to take you
20 minutes it's not a huge loot
maybe the dog had a chance to run around
in the field you know there's a bigger
what do police want to know that the
potentially people who haven't yet come
forward who would have seen her during
this period of time and that's really
been the appeal we've had you know I
think we've had three police press
conferences now maybe four actually and
every single time they've appealed for
more information people who were driving
on Blackpool Lane that morning to come
forward with dash cam footage in this
time window that we're going through
right now any other dog walkers that
morning who knew what Nicola looked like
who saw her dog Willow to come forward
and just give us some detail of what
happened in the 10 minute window which
has currently been unaccounted for this
is a busy dog walking area you know
there will have been uh you know a
number of dog walkers although you know
suggested to me that it was bitterly
cold that Friday morning you know there
weren't perhaps as many dog walkers as
you would normally suggest it was
incredibly muddy as well you know but
again you've been on the call I'm just
trying to think what she would have been
doing you know she'd been on the call
she'd been looking at the river the
snowdrops had just died across the way
there she would have been taking in this
Beauty Spot she's not from Lancashire
originally she's from Essex isn't she
and she's moved up to be with her
partner Paul Paul is absolutely sure
that she's not in that River yeah Paul
has said previously you know he is 100
sure that she's not in that River he
actually said that he would like police
to search you know every home speak to
every person in the area Caravan park
over there as well he wants this whole
place thoroughly combed police say look
we we've done that you know we have
investigated all the lines of inquiry in
this area where people they've searched
300 properties yeah so there's 300
properties they've searched one across
the road three Thai across the river
rather three times you can actually see
I don't know if the camera can see it
but the abandoned property
is just to our left here okay and that
is a property which has been surged and
police said look she's not she's not in
there and anyone who's come along and
you know people have actually tried to
break into that property at you know
armchair detectives coming and filming
on Tick Tock and things like that police
have won stay away from that she's not
in there someone still owns that
property well you just met them in Tick
Tock let me just before we move on
because in the next point when she was
spotted I was speaking to the council
leader in the seven o'clock hour I'm not
sure if you were with us or not
um and he was saying along here was like
the front at Windermere I mean the
number of people that have been here
um in order to try and be um sleuths or
whatever have their picture taken on the
bench whatever it was it's quite awesome
the family that you know yeah and it is
quite sad because look at the heart of
this story K you know there's a missing
woman and two girls at home without a
mum and they were yeah two little girls
yeah and people were rocking up here you
know in their dozens and it was like it
was like Blackpool seafront you know it
was like a circus at some stage people
filming and you know trying to spot
Nicola and trying to spot evidence you
know I think there was one stage where
someone called out there was something
green in the water it was a chair that
they went you know that police ended up
pulling out but you know people were
coming down here in their absolute
numbers to try and get a sense of what
had gone on but I think also it shows
the real interest that people have had
watching this from wherever they are so
she walked into the field she's seen um
a fellow dog walker who she knows the
dogs have had a little play uh they've
said the farewells
um and then moved on moved into the
upper field and she sends an email to
her boss
um and that is fired off and she
continues to walk along the top of this
field here and she starts to join a
team's conversation the camera's not on
the audio is not on but she is holding
it out and we know that because somebody
saw her right now yeah it was at 10 past
nine here on the upper field that
somebody then saw Nicola a witness that
has been spoken to by police so three
weeks ago let's put this in perspective
three weeks ago ten past nine in the
morning yeah somebody saw Nicola walking
with her dog Willow here that was then
interrogated by police police put a
picture of that witness out and that
witness came forward spoke to the police
gave us much information as they
possibly could and you know that was an
important juncture in this because that
was the last sighting yeah Nicola then
carried on with her walk still on the
call still on the call phone out in
front of her call on the speaker
listening to what was being said in this
meeting
the thing is now is you know we're not
actually that far okay from the upper
field to the bench further on
and it took 10 minutes 10 minutes from
here to I'm going to say 150 meters 10
minutes yeah you know so what's
happening well what has happened in that
10 minutes and that that is that really
is the big big question what police had
actually said you know her phone moved
towards the bench area that's what they
said so they can track that can they
yeah so with forensics that they've had
on the phone
they just said the phone moved towards
the bench area now look you know I think
that's quite unusual language because
that doesn't say you know nickel has
taken the phone to the bench that
doesn't say you know that um it was it
was directly placed in her hands into
the bench area it just said that the
phone was was moved towards the bench
area and that was between 10 past nine
someone seeing her on the upper field to
20 past nine uh that's where the phone
was moved to and actually subsequently
left all while still logged on this
teams caller a meeting so she's not
walking all this time obviously because
it's not a very far distance for her to
move no and you know maybe the dog is
running around remember the dog off the
lead running around she's
perhaps Willow has gone off somewhere
she's calling Willow maybe
um but you know she's she's not moving
quickly we can you know we can safely
say that because the upper field to the
bench ain't really that far doggy coming
um and you know just to illustrate you
know that this is where um the dog
walkers come
um all the time
um her partner came along Paul
and he's retraced these steps many times
hasn't he yeah he has he has and he came
down pretty much straight away you know
he wanted to see
what was the scene like what happened
here straight away good morning morning
sir
how are you no no not at all good to see
you you're Olivia it has been like that
so you you actually you saw the phone is
that right yeah yeah yeah you saw the
phone that Friday morning yes yeah and
that was around was it after half nine I
I gave a full statement to the police
with the exact ties because excuse me
because my wife's
yeah yeah yeah how's the last three
weeks been
each day something new comes out doesn't
it yeah you know yeah yeah yeah
and and in in terms of you know
when you saw phone lead and Willow who
you you knew who Nicola was no I didn't
you knew the willow that was it wasn't
you knew you knew what the you knew I'd
seen I'd see
um but both
bought the orders of Willow yeah walking
this dog in the passport whilst I knew
them back there it's like I know your
thing yes I didn't know the name yeah
yeah but but you I remember you actually
telling me when you saw the phone that
the lead and Willow you were like okay
I'm gonna keep an eye on it because
something doesn't feel right I thought
something had gone to the toilet in me
yeah you know that would have been that
was my first I got about this red brick
building here and I uh well this this is
not right and uh but then there was a
conversation but my wife was trying to
ring me I was trying to ring her Penny
had rung my wife yeah
um to say that she should fasten the dog
up that was that was and Penny was the
lady who actually spotted Willow
initially and saw the phone but didn't
know what was going on with the phone
right yeah yeah yeah and and then after
that you know
a progression of of of things happening
you know we found out a couple of the
wallpaper on the phone we found out who
the couple were then the school was
contacted and Paul arrived yeah well
look we'll let you carry on with your
walk I know you do this every morning
Nicola did this almost every morning as
well probably yeah we're retracing those
steps this time three weeks ago yeah so
an important no I know juncture thank
you very much take care all the best
I mean how important is that you know
someone who always wanted to walk about
the same time every day doesn't he yeah
and one of the first people who actually
spotted
you know the phone on the bench who was
contacted by
the lady who saw it first he came down
here he saw the wallpaper he saw a
picture yeah of who was on there
and then they knew and they contacted
the school because they must have
figured that the kids were at that
school yeah and that would have been the
first Contact and then police would have
been informed and then the search
operation and because it was high risk
they're reacted quickly
yeah that that was actually something
that they that they said initially when
they spoke to her partner Paul they
found out that he was high that that
Nicola was high risk and that she had
specific vulnerabilities they then
categorized her as high risk and then
they're like okay and that's because of
what had happened previously the police
had been called hadn't they yeah it was
17 days before
actually the 27th of January so the 10th
of January police had gone round to
Nicola and Paul's home because they had
reports of um concerns for welfare and
so look straight away
when that is taken to an account police
said to me that that Rings alarm Bells
you know that really does ring alarm
bells and straight away Nicola has
categorized as high risk just tell us
what happened when the police were
called
well the details are are limited K but
what what police have said it was 10th
of January they received those calls
they went round with health
professionals they say medical
professionals not entirely sure what
kind of triage team that is
but they go to the house no one was
arrested at the time
on these you know concerns for welfare
but what they have said is that they are
continuing to investigate what happened
on that day 17 days before Nicola went
missing
um
I'm just looking around as you're
chatting to me and I just look I you
know it there's nothing about this space
that makes you think that
um someone would have disappeared here
and I think that's the real shock to
this community and to you know people
like Ron the dog walker that we just
spoke to a real shock how on Earth has
you know the nation's eyes descended on
this small quaint Village in Lancashire
after a missing mum of two you know how
has that happened how is that even
possible and it's still you know three
weeks are no clues no evidence there was
a whopping question mark over what on
Earth happened three weeks ago this
morning excuse me so she's walking it's
slippy it would have been slippy when
she was here she's using Wellies as well
yeah which would have been tricky to
walk in
um
she's done the loop she's done the lower
field she's done the upper field she's
spoken to the boss she sent oh she sent
an email to her boss she's still got her
phone in front of her still on the
team's Court well this is it's in this
time now between 9 20 and 9 10 of the
the witness spotting Nicola and moving
to the bench it's this 10 minute window
where police the words from police are
her phone moved towards the bench area
so how how did it travel to the bench
area that's a big question we still
don't exactly know that this way
and then this is the river bank we
wander down this way so this is the bank
a lot of people have been asking about
the bank and how steep it is doesn't
look that steep does it no it doesn't in
some areas but if
all the way to the bank no it doesn't
but then if you look Further Down K
there is a bit of a drop are you
comfortable going down there there is a
bit of a drop down there and look it's
muddy so please be very careful it's
muddy and slippy and it would have been
probably even muddier at the time a lot
of people have trampled on here
in the three weeks since nickel has been
missing a lot of people have gone down
to peep over the bank and see if they
can spot anything police have been down
here as well it is yeah police have also
you know with divers and and um and and
drones and underwater cameras have all
been down here
but clearly a bit of a drop off from the
bank down there so if we move back up
yeah and so this is this is the part of
the river where the police think that
she has gone into the water there's no
sign here at all of um you know any
scuffs or whatever yeah but this is
where her phone is found yeah well look
it's 9 20. yeah right now yeah
9 20 three weeks ago
Nicholas phone had moved to this bench
and this is what police say it was here
that her phone had ended up I'm not
entirely sure exactly where it was
placed but her phone was on a bench yeah
here
and that's where that's where the team
calls it was still ongoing by the way it
was on speaker
she hadn't spoken in it she hadn't got
her camera on but the phone was on the
bench here
and then the dog walker that we just saw
did you say his name was Ron yes Ron but
I mean that that come that comes later
on actually because Ron was you know he
was one of the first people
to notice what had what had gone over
here in terms of the phone the lead and
the dog there was actually a another
lady who owns a caravan Park here she
was the first person to notice Willow
scurrying between the bench and uh and
the kissing gate just there but it was 9
20. so around this time the phone the
phone's still on speaker the teams call
still going A team's call with her her
work she was a mortgage advisor she just
you know got got a deal a mortgage deal
just a few days ago
her parents told her she was you know in
good spirits about work she sent an
email to her boss
earlier that morning and you know this
is where she ended up well this is where
the phone ended up is what police this
has never been cordoned off
no and you know look that that's a
really big talking point and has been a
huge there's lots of questions around
that straight away police said that she
was high risk that she was a missing
person so there are big questions as to
whether why
there weren't there weren't there wasn't
a cordon around here you know there was
there was huge questions because it it
enabled people and we've seen dozens and
dozens and dozens of people to come here
sit on the bench walk down to the bank
you know and and triple uh trample over
essentially evidence let's just talk
about this because this is the this is a
spot isn't it
um the police think she's gone into the
water there they have looked searched
this River
beneath they've had divers they've had
all sorts of people here to try to find
out what's going on they think that she
is in the water
her partner and the family think that
that is not what she would have done she
just would not have gone into the water
her phone's here the dog is running
around
um
but I know there's a gentleman standing
there but I just wanted to illustrate
the kissing gate being just there there
we go he's just moved it off
um kissing Gates there that stretch
there that we walked down about 40
minutes ago doesn't have any CCTV no it
doesn't so what happened in this 10
minutes this is the big question this is
the vital 10 minutes that we're in right
now that police are trying to understand
what happened from 9 20 when Nicholas
phone ended up at this bench still
logged into that team's call to 9 30
when that team's call ended but Nicholas
stayed logged in that that is a real
crucial 10 minute window that police are
trying to establish what could have
happened right what what are the options
Nicola as police believe could have
ended up in the river wire
how she got there is the big question
why she went in there is the other big
question Nicola the other hypothesis
working hypothesis that police are
keeping an open mind to they tell us
that but believe did not happen there
could have been some third-party
involvement some criminality I don't
think of crimes they don't think so but
it's a hypothesis that they have to
you know keep investor and keep
investigating the third option is as you
mentioned Nicola could have gone through
the kissing gate down the path
the river path and out next to Blackpool
Lane if she turned right
CCTV camera would have spotted her so
police are clear she did not go out that
path onto that busy road and turn right
if she turned left however there is back
to the car yes towards the church and
towards the school there is no CCTV yet
that they've established or dash cam
footage that has spotted her so that is
also a bit of a blind spot at the minute
for police so there are two kind of
hypotheses that they are working on one
is the main one that she ended up in the
river the other one is that potential
blind spot of if she turned left when
coming out of the river path but another
thing police have always said throughout
all this they believe that Nicola did
not leave this area that she did not
leave the fields that is why
they are working on that main hypothesis
that she ended up into what is a cold a
very deep and in some parts a very
fast-flowing River
um
really and the
crime could have potentially have been
committed here and I can't I can't
comprehend that a dog owner would leave
the dog here and walk up that path yeah
I mean we've heard we've heard a lot of
different you know arguments and ideas
and people even telling us this morning
in the program
but if nikra had gone in the water the
dog probably would have followed this is
the dog this is a dog that swims we've
actually seen images of Willow the Dog
um wet and in water before so we know
that the dog wouldn't have been afraid
to go in so we're just seeing Ron go now
and we saw where we picked him up so it
gives you an idea that it's actually
it's quite a short Loop here isn't it
yeah it's quite it's quite a short loop
I mean I think Ron's joined us straight
down the path and come yeah come back up
I mean but Nicola's you know walk around
wasn't that you know that that long it
wasn't it wasn't a huge distance
but again it comes back to the question
what was her frame of mind that morning
Kay what was she feeling what was she
thinking I'm sure all that kind of stuff
you know kind of affects the way you
walk the way that you are in a morning
you know was she walking quickly clearly
not because it's taken a long time she
was taking her time sending emails on a
team's call that team's called still
ongoing right now this time three until
9 30. UM the police have debunked some
of the
um ridiculous Rumors by the fishermen
covering their faces and there was a van
that they wanted to talk about but they
do want more CCTV 700 Vehicles so far
yeah it's dash cam footage which is
vital you're right you know look there's
been so many different theories and
police coming out on the 14th of Feb
with the assistant chief Constable with
the senior investigating officer for the
first time in this case we saw her and
they were adamant they that wanted this
to dispel a lot of those theories from
people namely you know who hadn't come
down to the scene
and that was a a clear aim for them on
the 14th they came out in force and they
wanted to dispel those theories I think
they did that I think that's fair to say
and it drew people back to right what is
their main working hypothesis now but
obviously in that press conference as
well we heard you know the kind of shock
bombshell really that Nicola you know
had specific vulnerabilities and that
she you know was high risk at that
moment and the Home Secretary wants
Lancashire police to explain why they've
talked about alcoholism uh or um misuse
of alcohol shall we say and also uh the
menopause what's that got to do with it
um so from when we arrived here and we
were telling you about the phone on the
bed which was about ten past nine it was
about about 20 past nine so there's like
there's 10 minutes now so the 10 minutes
we've been standing here something has
happened yeah and that's the big
question that's the 10 minutes why she's
disappeared you know that is what police
are trying to identify her phone was on
the bench did Nikki sit on the bench did
she take some time out sat on the bench
was her dog Willow roaming around you
know was he near the water's edge you
know did he go towards the bank was he
having a look over in the water
Nikki's phone was placed on the bench
she was still listening to that team's
call but what happened in that 10
minutes but we don't know she was there
that is the big question the phone was
there yeah police are adamant the phone
was there but where was Nikki where was
Nicola bully in that 10 minutes three
weeks ago today and that's a question
that police are really just
trying to answer but it's you know it's
not as if this place is scattered with
CCTV we're in you know a big Field small
area such a small area so Ronnie we just
chatted to he saw the dog running around
he saw the phone on the bench and there
was literally no sign whatsoever of
Nicola
um he saw the screenshot on the front
the wallpaper on the front of the phone
recognized them went to the school
alerted the school who got Paul her
partner who came down very quickly and
and then the search began yeah and three
weeks later and essentially you know
that that search kicked into action
straight away by Lancashire police
excuse me and you know they they really
brought in a lot of Specialists to try
and search for Nicola bully it was my
understanding that actually that search
reduced over the last few days or so but
we're at a very important juncture right
now okay it's 9 30.
30 minutes team call that ended and
she'd logged on about 901 it had
obviously started at nine o'clock yeah
um but she stayed logged on so police
say that the team's call ended 9 30.
but Nicola's phone remained logged on to
that team's call in other words she
hadn't ended the call it was still on
there the phone was on the bench where
was Nicola
the phone was still unlocked
the phone was discovered then in two
minutes time or so but
again it was what had happened in that
10 minute window the phone was here but
the the call was logged on
no one had cut it off yeah
yeah and the dog was here as well and as
we said the the dog walker run who we
spoke to was one of the first here he
knew who the phone belonged to yeah so
what actually happened then in the
minutes after that team call ended
a nearby uh resident lives in the house
just around the corner here she was
walking her dogs and had noticed Willow
was scurrying between the bench here and
the kissing gate that's what
this dog walker had noticed what she
then did she actually got a bit of
string she told me and tied Willow up
to the leg of the bench yeah just to
stop her running around she saw that the
lead was on the the harness it was was
on the floor she noticed her phone was
on the bench
she then contacted
some of her friends to try and
understand what to do next
and then
Ron who we spoke to earlier was the
second person to come along and see
absolutely everything that was left here
the phone
the lead
and Willow tied up to the bench and then
that's when things really started to get
into action because
yes they noticed that the phone was
still unlocked
Ron spoke to his wife someone had gone
to the lou didn't he yeah he actually
said oh he thought someone had nipped
off over there gone to the Loo left the
left the dog you know tied up and yeah
but actually when they saw on the lock
screen of Nikki's phone there was an
image
yes there was an image of Nikki and her
partner Paul that resonated and then
things kicked into action where they
thought okay we better call the school
because we know that Nikki's got kids
there and the school then picked it up
from there contacted the police and the
investigation started so that happened
um
three weeks ago right now yeah
approximately police say it was 9 33
three weeks ago that the lady who who
owns a caravan Park just around the
corner here
actually spotted Nicholas phone spotted
Willow and spotted the harness she was
another dog walker so you know she she
noticed who Willow was noticed with
Willow belonged to and then that's when
things really kicked into action I know
the locals got involved yeah so that's
like the the 45 minutes
from when she dropped the children off
at school we walk we've walked her walk
today starting in the car park walking
along Blackpool Lane going past the 16th
century Parish Church very beautiful
building walking down
to where we are and then going around
the loop the lower field and then up to
the upper field sending an email to her
boss saying hello to people that she
knew along the way dialing into a team's
call just after it started at nine
o'clock making a way to where we are now
we know well we know that her phone made
its way to here it was left on the bench
the dog was here the harness was here
there was literally no further sign of
Nicola and that has been the case for
the last three weeks it has been
perplexing for Lancashire police it has
been devastating for her family we'll
have continuing coverage here on Sky